e aí
e essa fala sobre racismo mas é para os
brancos inicialmente quando nós falamos
de racismo em geral as pessoas pensam um
lá vem alguém falar sobre negro ou lá
vem alguém falar sobre indígena mas eu
venho para falar qual é a
responsabilidade de nós brancos na luta
anti-racista o que nós brancos podemos
fazer para melhorar a sociedade
brasileira e por que melhorar a
sociedade brasileira porque o racismo é
um problema de todos nós hoje no final
do dia quando anoitecer vão ter morrido
oitenta e três jovens negros nas
periferias desse país morrido pela
guerra às drogas morrido também pela
seletividade penal na qual a polícia age
na sociedade brasileira você já
conseguiram imaginar o que são 83 jovens
pense
é aquele avião que cai e aparece na
televisão e a gente fica super chocado
porque a gente sabe que aquela moça
queria encontrar o marido que ela não
via tempo que aquela filha aí é
encontrar aquela mãe que tava doente e
talvez fosse a última vez que ela ganhou
se ver aquela outra menina tinha juntado
dinheiro por mais de dez anos para fazer
aquele curso de francês esses 83 jovens
que no final do dia de hoje vão ter sido
assassinados também tem sonhos também
tocavam piano tocavam um instrumento que
vão ficar em silêncio também tem sonhos
também tem mãe e talvez e foi a última
vez que eles viram essas pessoas no
final do dia de hoje nós temos
responsabilidade na luta anti-racista
porque é muito importante entender qual
é o lugar que a gente como branco ocupa
nessa sociedade e principalmente
entender que se a gente não se engajar
nessa luta não tem
a mudança por isso eu peço que todos
vocês pensem né nesse momento quando que
raça foi um problema para vocês quando
que vocês pensaram o que significa ser
branco
olá me chamo vocês para pensar nisso
nesse momento na sociedade brasileira a
gente costuma dizer que a gente não é
racista né essa frase eu não sou racista
ela deveria ser traduzida por eu não
tive a intenção de ser racista por que
todos nós aprendemos acessar ser racista
todos os dias desde que a gente nasce a
gente aprende a ser racista na sociedade
brasileira por isso o racismo tem que
ser retirado do âmbito moral no que que
eu tô querendo dizer todas as pessoas
querem ter uma imagem boa de si mesmo
por isso te falar eu sou racista talvez
seja tão complicado ou assumir que foi
educado como racista seja tão complicado
porque a gente quer ter uma imagem boa
de nós mesmos e o racismo na sociedade
brasileira está no âmbito moral daqueles
que a gente pensa moralmente eu sou bom
moralmente eu sou ruim então se eu sou
uma pessoa que quero ser boa eu não sou
racista só que não é
como funciona na sociedade brasileira
porque a gente tem algo que é racismo
estrutural o que que é o racismo
estrutural o racismo estrutural é como
se estrutura a sociedade brasileira ou
seja quem tem filho aqui levanta a mão
para mim para vocês trabalharem em geral
40 horas quem tem filho e quem trabalha
40 horas que tem filho aqui 40 horas
alguém fica com filho de vocês né ou é
alguém que não ganha nada que pode ser
uma avó que pode ser uma cunhada que
pode ser a esposa ou é alguém que ganha
muito menos que pode ser a professora da
escola pública ou que pode ser uma babá
uma empregada se essas pessoas que estão
cuidando do filho de vocês enquanto que
vocês trabalham 40 horas ganharem a
mesma coisa quem é que vai sair de casa
para trabalhar ninguém porque a
o que você ganhar vai ser equivalente a
o que você vai ter que pagar por isso
nós precisamos de uma estrutura desigual
para viver num país como nós estamos o
racismo é estrutural na sociedade
brasileira ele estrutura essa sociedade
o que que é estruturar pensem essas
esses pilares certo se esses pilares
caírem o prédio cai se as cadeiras
saírem daqui não acontece nada a gente
pode remontar se nós tirarmos o racismo
da sociedade brasileira ea desigualdade
que a raça traz a gente tem que remontar
a sociedade ou seja nós precisamos que
os trabalhos de todas as pessoas cuscuz
com que trabalham 40 horas dentro de
casa uma empresa não valão tão
diferentemente ou seja a gente precisa
mudar a sociedade e retirar o racismo o
racismo faz com que essas pessoas sejam
tão valorizadas que o trabalho que elas
ocultam ganha
ou menos né a um dado na pra sociedade
brasileira que mesmo os mesmos cargos
com a mesma educação os negros ganham
trinta por cento ao menos o que as
pessoas brancas né nos mesmos cargos
imagine como se ocupa cargos tão
diferente então nós temos um racismo que
estrutura a sociedade brasileira e a
gente aprende a ser racista se eu pedir
para como pela ideia de raça a ideia de
raça a ideia de que um fenótipo ou seja
a aparência física vai ter uma
continuidade é interna ou seja o externo
vai ter uma continuar uma continuidade
interna quando a gente fala os japoneses
são determinados a gente tá usando a
ideia de raça quando a gente diz os
negros dançam bem a gente tá usando a
ideia de raça a gente tá pegando uma
aparência e tá usando uma ideia moral
mas é intelectual uma ideia estética
essa ideia de raça surge no ocidente com
uma ideia de superioridade
e brancos e ela funciona assim uma
superioridade moral e intelectual e
estética talvez por isso quando cai esse
avião cheio de pessoas brancas a gente
olha fala meu deus essas pessoas se
parecem comigo e quando morre no final
de todos os dias na sociedade brasileira
83 jovens negros a gente não se abale da
mesma forma isso se chama né pactos
narcísicos entre o branco o que que é
isso mãe intelectual brasileira chamada
maria aparecida bento ela cunhou esse
termo o que é o seguinte é um
silenciamento de nós pessoas brancas
sobre a questão racial é a
invisibilidade da ideia de raça para as
pessoas brancas se eu perguntar para
todas as pessoas aqui está tendo o
racismo neste momento nesse ambiente
difícil alguém mente alguém vai falar
assim porque o que que a gente imagina
que é racismo é quando a gente trata mal
alguém mas não é verdade quando a gente
tem um público que a
a branca e que quase todas as pessoas
que frequentam são branca a gente tem
racismo e esse racismo chama racismo
institucional que é uma instituição uma
organização qualquer instituição
brasileira quando ela é incapaz de
promover igualdade entre as diferenças
raças ou seja nós temos esse racismo
como estrutura ea estrutura da sociedade
brasileira ela tem a ver com as
instituições o racismo estrutural tem
que está relacionado ao poder econômico
ao poder político e poder de decisão
econômica poderes decisão política e
poder de produção de subjetividade
quando a gente está falando de
instituições e lugares de poder a gente
está falando de poder econômico e poder
político e quando a gente está falando
de produção de subjetividade a gente tá
falando dos veículos que produzem easter
e como a mídia a indústria cultural a
televisão essa sociedade inteira
em todos os grupos podem ter preconceito
contra os outros e várias vezes as
pessoas me pergunta para mim é mas não
tem racismo reverso não tem racismo
branco contra não do negro contra o
branco ou não tem racismo do indígena
contra o branco e a resposta é não não
tem pode existir preconceito pode
existir discriminação mas esses grupos
não tem poder eu sempre dou um exemplo
que é o seguinte algum de vocês que
estão aqui levanta e não para mim sabem
que é juruá
e não juruá é como os kaiowás os
indígenas kaiowá no meião as pessoas
brancas e juruá em geral está
relacionada a aspectos negativos
destruidor de natureza né ou alguém que
avança sobre a terra dos outros esses
são os juros ah são os homens brancos
isso já em algum momento abalou a vida
das pessoas que estão aqui por serem
juro a você já foram impedidos de entrar
em algum lugar porque vocês são juro a
vocês foram discriminados na rua porque
são de lá não porque eles podem ter
preconceito eles podem ser feliz
periódico mas não tem poder econômico
poder político e o poder de produzir
subjetividade ou seja de articular o que
é juruá para todas as pessoas saberem
aqui só que os brancos tiveram esse
poder um poder da colonização o poder
econômico o poder político então um
racismo e o preconceito
o que foi vindo construído qual a
sociedade branca foi circulando por toda
a sociedade por isso que nós todos
sabemos o que significa nessa sociedade
o racismo e como que é o olhar do branco
sobre o negro e como que isso tem
atrelado à ideia de superioridade então
a branquitude né que essa identidade
racial do branco é a ideia de que nós
brancos também temos raça só que quando
a gente fala de raça a gente sempre acha
que nós vamos falar de negros indígenas
a branquitude é um lugar confortável
onde a gente olha os outros com um olho
e com uma lente que não olha a si mesmo
que é a ideia de raça eu vou dar um
exemplo bem fácil a gente sempre vem
revista roupas étnicas alguém já viu
isso quando vocês vem roupas étnicas
vocês já pensaram em terno e gravata
em geral gente pensa em roupa indiana
roupa africana roupa de indígena terno e
gravata também é uma roupa edna é porque
o que que é ser étnico é um grupo que
tem costumes e que esses costumes né
cinco tem símbolos e tem significados e
as roupas por exemplo significam algo o
terno e gravata tem um significado na
nossa sociedade logo ela é uma roupa que
representa algo para nossa cultura assim
como colocar representa algo para
algumas culturas indígenas só que o cara
é visto como étnico o terno e gravata é
visto como roupa normal você já pensaram
aqui hoje vou sair de casa vestido de
branco faz sentido não porque a
branquitude é isso é esse lugar que se
sente o padrão de humanidade enquanto os
outros são vistos forma diferente e o
que tá no âmbito disso é que as
conquistas
é de grupo das pessoas brancas são
vistas como conquistas individuais que
isso significa que cada conquista das
pessoas brancas são vistas como mérito
pessoal se eu perguntar dentro de uma
empresa onde todos os trabalhadores
fases que estão no lugar de poder são
brancos o que você fez para chegar aqui
e o que que vai ser a resposta eu
estudei muito eu trabalhei eu tenho os
esquilos ou seja eu tenho as
instrumentos os instrumentos necessários
que a empresa tem eu sei falar inglês e
a sua empresa precisava você consegue
imaginar que alguém vai responder eu tô
aqui porque eu sou branco
e eu dou aula na universidade federal de
santa catarina nós somos em 52
professores 51 brancos você consegue
imaginar que alguém inclusive eu vou
falar eu estou aqui eu passei nesse
concurso porque eu sou branco
e não ou seja as conquistas que tem isso
não significa que a pessoa não estudou
não teve realmente mérito ou não
investir energia mas as oportunidades
que ela teve está relacionado a ela ser
branca ou seja as conquistas que fazem
parte de um grupo e tem a ver com o
pertencimento a um privilégio que é a
branquitude na sociedade brasileira são
vistas como individuais enquanto as
conquistas dos negros e dos indígenas
são visto ele entrou aqui por causa do
que ele tem porque ele é negro e são
cotas uma vez eu tive uma colega minha
que falou o seguinte eu não pego mais
aluno e não é uma colega daqui é de
outro lugar de do espírito santo eu não
pego mais aluno negro ele para orientar
porque ele deu muito trabalho é sempre
muito tenso é muito tenso e eu perguntei
mais que está falando ah é sempre essa
coisa é o que você tá falando não é o
que eu gostaria me chama de branco fala
que eu não tô entendendo que
a pessoa quer colocar raça e é muito
muito tenso aí eu perguntei para ela
quantas pessoas brancas você já orientou
e mestrado doutorado que foi tenso aí
ela falou o joão foi bem difícil a
fernanda foi muito difícil a maria
também não foi uma relação boa e aí eu
perguntei você já pensou em orientar
mais brancos
bom então mas foi a maria foi o joão foi
a fernanda enquanto a dificuldade que o
aluno negro não tinha nem nome o mário
não tinha nem nome era o aluno negro ele
representa o grupo como um todo eu tô
falando isso porque é uma desigualdade
simbólica em que o branco é sempre o
indivíduo e que negros indígenas são
sempre vistos como parte de um grupo
ninguém pergunta os brancos o seguinte
você como branco o que que você acha do
presidente da república de hoje você
como branco o que você acha do bolsonaro
a gente responde ué eu como pessoa mas
as pessoas perguntam você como negro o
que você acha do obama você como o negro
que que você acha do movimento social
nego você como o negro que que você acha
dessa reportagem aqui sobre negro
imagine se perguntar se você como branco
que você acha da maioria dos lobos
a ser em branco você como branco ou seja
cada um de nós segura a bandeira de ser
só um enquanto essas outras pessoas são
parte de um grupo eu tô falando tudo
isso porque nós aprendemos a ser racista
e a gente tem que desaprender e a gente
precisa se admitir como alguém que
aprendeu a ser racista né nesse sentido
não há como você sentir parte de
resolução de um problema se você não faz
parte dele se o racismo é do outro se o
acima daquele colega lá de longe por quê
que você vai se envolver quando a gente
entender que nós somos parte do problema
e que nós temos que estar nessa luta
junto nós vamos conseguir ser
anti-racista e numa sociedade onde tem
racismo estrutural não basta que todas
as pessoas aqui falem eu não sou racista
nós temos ser anti-racista e
anti-racista são práticas e são práticas
diárias uma vez o que que nós podemos
fazer cada um pode fazer do tamanho
o que você é nossa sociedade uma criança
de 5 anos pode responder para outra
criança de 5 anos esse cabelo enrolado é
lindo sim certo é isso que ele pode
fazer na luta anti-racista um dono de
empresa pode pensar muito bem como que
ele contrata as pessoas que ele contrata
quais são as barreiras que ele precisa
retirar que estão impedindo que os
negros entre nessa empresa tá precisando
de inglês mas está precisando mesmo de
inglês essas pessoas vão usar em inglês
ou em inglês é só um corte que vai
ajudar entrar só quem fez intercâmbio
uma vez eu fui numa empresa fazer um
trabalho para inclusão de negros na
empresa e o inglês era algo que era
necessário e aí eu perguntei quantos de
vocês já usaram inglês neste trabalho
ninguém respondeu todo mundo falou que
não ou seja o inglês só servia para
impedir ou como barreira de que os
negros e pobres entrasse naquela empresa
quais são as barreiras que a gente pode
ir retirando nos lugares de poder em que
a gente ocupa que não tá de
e os negros entre em suas carreiras no
nesses lugares e aí tá desde relacionado
uma vez uma dona de casa falou o
seguinte para mim e eu não tenho nada o
que fazer eu sou meu dentro de casa eu
falei que tem você já viu quais são as
bonecas que tua filha tem é que boneca
nega não são apenas para os negros se
sentirem representados mas muito
importante para que os brancos parem se
sentir centro do mundo eles também
precisam de bonecas negras professores
negros é alunos negros na escola não são
apenas para os negros se sentirem que
podem chegar lá mas principalmente para
os brancos pensar em essas pessoas têm o
mesmo lugar que eu nós temos igualdade
de representação e eu termino com a
frase da jane elliot naquele filme olhos
azuis ela pergunta para todas as pessoas
brancas que estavam presente o seguinte
se você gostaria de ser tratado como os
negros são na sociedade americana todas
as pessoas respondem que não ou seja os
brancos sabem que os negros são tratados
de forma diferente e depois ela pergunta
de novo então por que você deixa que
isso aconteça com os outros é
responsabilidade nossa lutar contra o
racismo eu espero que cada dia amanhã de
manhã vocês acorda e pensa e quais são
as práticas anti-racista que eu posso
fazer na minha vida obrigado a
e aí